OK, let's drop back in and move over to June 2023.
So far, the lowest win rate.
Maybe we'll bring that back up.
What's very interesting, actually,
is that we did 2025, February, March, April, May,
and we took 32 trades.
2023, we did February, March, April, May,
and we took the exact same amount of trades.
Interesting.
For all of 2024, we did 109 trades, which is, well, 10.9 per month.
And February, March, April, May, 32 divided by 4 is around about 8.
So we've still seen the same average of around about 8 to 10 trades
on average per month.
But without further ado, let's get June, June, July wrapped up.
Good old indicator that never saves.
[ Silence ]
The first of June, let me just kind of get my bearings back
to where we were.
Let me make sure that the sessions are correct, 2 to 5, 7 to 10.
I believe we may have just shifted bullish.
I believe we did just shift bullish.
Cool.
So we have shifted bullish for New York.
Oh, yeah, we already looked at London.
Sorry, my bad.
If you remember, the last session, kind of skipped ahead a little bit too fast,
but that's fine.
First of June, we have ISM at 10.
So if we pull back, yeah, not really.
Well, okay, not ideal, but cool.
That shift is bearish.
That would be a trade, but there's not going to be a tag.
Yeah, just messy price action, just fine.
So now, we bearish is Friday the 2nd of June, oh wait, is that NFP?
Yes, it's not the 2nd of June.
It is Monday the 5th of June, we have ISM to a balance of trade.
And again, really just not nice structure, not terrible.
And now it's not nice.
I wouldn't trade, obviously I don't use Asia hires, my stick.
Cool.
Cool, that's bullish.
Choose it as sick, June.
We are now officially bullish, and this becomes our technical swing loss, so
there's going
to be no trade here.
That technically shifts as bearish, maybe in New York.
Okay, so we are bearish, a bit better price action, if we can get the sweep but
we're
going in the opposite direction.
7th of June, we have balance of trade.
Okay, we're running the wrong direction until we're looking for shorts, oh wait
a minute,
there's definitely shorts in there.
It has to be.
Pretty much M5.
There you go, M3 invert, there you go, yeah, equal hives.
Can we go to single timeframe, please?
I would reduce this loss to, yeah, 0.2%, but then if we react from that level,
start trading
away from it, like this for example, yeah, it doesn't really matter.
Again, loss reduction, it's the important part because like you look and you
might see
25% win rate, right, but you're not factoring in the fact that 25% win rate,
but the average
win to lose the average win to loss ratio is above five, right?
So, I mean, we can even figure it out right now, because of the loss management
, like
a lot of these trades that were taken, it's like 0.6, 0.5, right, 0.3, for
example, we
are profitable, we are profitable with a 14.3% win rate, right?
That's kind of the bare minimum profitability.
So anything over 14.3% win rate is profitable and does it, is it good
management?
It's always good management, okay, not always, but.
Okay.
So, let's go.
Again, the data is already telling us that the time of execution doesn't really
, there's
no variance.
There is a variance, however, with weak areas of interest, which is what they
're called
weak in the first place.
Wait, we just shifted bullish.
The one annoying thing is that, like, the structure, like, look at that price
action,
please.
Like, look at that.
Price is moving up, down, up, down, down, like, it's a horrible, horrible price
action.
Okay.
This is eight, it's four p.m.
We don't actually have any news.
Basically, one, five.
Nope.
Maybe New York.
That would be a trade idea.
Complete.
No news, no news, no news, no news, no news, no news, no news, no news, no news
.
Probably m5 in third, so where you got?
Yep.
There's kind of really no amounts of land.
Tag, then, strap.
I'm going to go back to the next slide.
Okay.
There's no news, no news, no news, no news, no news, no news, no news, no news,
no news.
Okay.
I'm not actually in this type of scenario.
We'll break that high like I'm telling you.
I need to test this, but I'm telling you I'm moving stops to here.
It just doesn't make sense anymore.
That would be 100% stops move to that level.
Like active trade management.
The session finished on a Friday, million percent are moving that to here.
But then do I, am I interfering with the data by doing that?
I'll leave it for now.
Because at least at the end, what I can do is come through, it's another thing.
I can through every single losing trade and try to understand it like, okay,
price was,
price tagged me in and then traded and it give this and then could I have
reduced risk?
Always about downside management.
I knew it.
I can see it in the price action.
Oh, there's the note, so it's happened on a previous trade as well.
I think that that's something that that management principle, that is something
that's going to take,
again, the average, average losing value of a trade significantly lower.
Because if right now we're at like six times more player, which I think we are,
I think I can get that to like a seven times more player.
Just off of aggressive management.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
It's off.
Yeah, still long.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
That's just bullshit.
Apologies, excuse my friend.
But it is, like.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Theoretically can't trade because of that candle on this type of setup.
Is there any news?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Yeah, but in New York.
There's no way that I wouldn't trade that.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Even though I have to put it down in this discretion, but that's just total.
Excuse my French, but it is.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Like, that's a good trade.
Doesn't matter anyway.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Yeah, that's fine.
Well, at least it didn't tag anyway.
But that would have been really annoying.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Is there news this day?
There is, right?
We'll just check.
Retail sales.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Ah, 8.30.
Damn.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Cool.
Pretty much might as well just go to London session.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Well, at least we moved out of this.
But that gives the explanation.
This is now just one huge accumulation.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
But we are so high.
Not anymore.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
But I don't really know how that works.
I don't think so.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
It's interesting though.
Again, this is a little bit of a very difficult one.
I have Michigan at 10.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Do I want to try to do that Michigan?
I mean, technically that gives us out.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Is it good for us to reward?
Not entirely.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I have to say it right here.
The time is at 9.30.
So I'll technically be getting in.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Oh, the news.
That would be pretty much.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Yeah.
I didn't ask you to trade.
Because again, I don't want to be in the trade through the Michigan.
I didn't know what it was going to give a reaction to, but we would have been
tagged in at like 9.35, which is like 25 minutes.
From news with news approaching, probably would have been able to move our
stops to break even.
But tagged in, price pushed away.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I think it might even trade below that low.
But it was so close to news.
Like it probably just wasn't executed in the live market.
Well, not probably.
Like I just wasn't off.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Not because it's so close.
Like maybe an hour away, yeah.
Time to get to break even, manage the trade and work and stuff.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
This is Monday.
No news.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
That's unfortunate.
That would have been a good start.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Contrary to.
We'd have an age of high up there at the highs, but.
Do with it.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
That's a serve, I think.
Oh, not this again.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Here we go.
Okay, at least that's.
That's okay.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Oh, no.
I think we're good.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Maybe not.
But we are bearish, so we can use the internal.
Why haven't I seen an internal?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
That would be a technically discretionary trade.
Perfect.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
It's not ideal, but.
No, it does take up.
That would be the actual.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Yeah.
Turn it over to the brake structure.
That does.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Brake even.
Power is about to start speaking.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Brake can work even.
Technically it's good management.
Don't miss out on any gains.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Why does it sometimes just not explode?
I haven't missed any.
That would be a London sweep on Asia into a strong point of interest during the
London session.
It's an entirely bearish.
I feel like I'm here to play Cludo.
It was Johnny in the kitchen with the knife.
I feel like Cludo changed the character continuation trend.
It's like it was London sweep Asia.
Strong, internal car trend.
Trending.
Premium discount.
There's no news.
Approximately.
4.45 a.m.
and it should be flagged for this.
And off we go.
20 second in June.
I think we're in drawdown for June.
Really frustrating price action.
Like this is just not last price action.
I mean.
I think it's technically trade.
I'm like three pips top now.
3.9.
It is 3.15.
And we have no news.
And we shall not be targeted into that position.
And that's the end of the session anyway.
Which is quite the bit frustrating, but sometimes they happen.
If you would have used that you got.
Now I would have used M15 all day.
There's no clear and obvious in both of you guys.
But if we did.
We still would have not.
Profit.
So doesn't really matter.
That is a.
Okay.
And we had fit pal.
We tried that.
I believe so.
It's one of those scenarios again as well.
Like this.
And as price expands upwards.
Right as price gives that type of reaction.
There's nothing left mitigated.
And so instead of having a full 1% stop open why not have 0.3% stop.
Right.
And how many losing trades.
Could we apply that principle to.
And how many of the winning trades gave that reaction.
And then traded back under this level and then traded higher.
And if you take get both of the data.
Go all the data for both of those.
And you run the math on them you'll understand there's a good rule or not.
Right.
That's how you actually build an edge.
That's how you actually trade in general.
Let the data decide.
We're having a really bad June.
This is.
I haven't had one of these subs in a while.
Thank you.
Difficult.
Honestly difficult price action again.
There's just no point.
They've been looking at New York.
Okay.
And 26 of June.
We have.
A CB four months into banking.
Fair enough.
Thank you.
That's just sad.
Well, again, that's just a reality.
Sometimes that is how it's going to be.
Is it good management?
Almost definitely.
At least we have really good management.
But honestly, sometimes that's just how it's going to be.
If we would have just used the first area I was looking at.
It ends up obviously hitting your first take profit.
Just not much you can do about it.
Sometimes the market is going to favor you.
Sometimes not.
It just is what it is.
Okay.
It's 26 of June.
You have nothing in New York session.
It looks like it.
That's true, right?
Well, the line has disappeared.
Eva, I am.
It looks like it's true to me, like ever so slightly, but through.
And then this bullish one trade through as well.
Eva, I've been looking at this screen for far too long.
Well, that trades through.
What type of difference does it make?
Is it a case of either way they both end up breaking.
Anyway, type of thing.
Okay, let's have a look at this.
There is a trade, I think.
The question is, is what is the outcome?
So does it change the outcome first and foremost?
Does that break?
Because I don't want to sit here and say, yeah, it breaks.
And then you at home think that it doesn't break.
But then again, if it breaks, it should be visible.
I think if it breaks, it becomes visible.
I don't think, but then that also to me looks like a break right now.
Yeah, it does.
That breaks through, right?
Don't forget the line itself.
Honestly.
And that also breaks the black handle.
Oh, it's at the same price level.
Can't break.
Yeah, either I am.
I must be seeing things or something.
Okay, let's just say it didn't break.
Because it's at the same price, if that becomes the trade,
which is probably going to be this entire range,
then it pretty much anyway becomes a break even.
And if it was this,
I think it also became a break even now.
No, probably wouldn't.
Okay, we're going to go with this.
But this anyway becomes a break even.
Break.
No tag.
Tag.
Break of structure.
Really and truly.
I'll probably go break even here.
At least like that.
And then there.
I'm going at least here.
But if not, honestly.
No, I'm going to review it.
That's mitigated on every timeframe you look at.
Which then becomes the break even.
And just to be clear.
Okay.
Where's this went hot?
Here's you.
Here's premium.
Sometimes all you need is one trade.
I'm going to go back to 27.
Nope.
Wait a minute.
Sometimes already there's one winning trade.
I'm in winning trade.
That is a trade though.
Tag.
Okay.
I don't really like that.
Tag.
See, now I understand.
We're bullish.
We are bullish.
Tag.
- Yeah.